about ten years ago I played in a  tournament and somehow my opponent as he  was playing pushed his a pawn to a three  and you know as a chess player you  should know where all the pieces are  right so calculated all this line  probably about five six moves and ended  up playing a line that would bring me  the win because at the end of play rupee  three and just win some material I play  Ruby three and he captures with a pawn  in b3 and I started saying I was  seriously what they're doing the phone  was in 83 you cannot capture my room and  he was like no I never played that pot  and I was looking on the honest [ __ ]  and I realized that yes indeed he never  did that but everybody saw it that it  was a 93 so he ended up offering me a  draw and I said no I don't want to draw  I'm winning but what do you mean and  then I realized that actually I was lost  so I took the draw but that was really  embarrassing for not remembering